(electronic music)
- We're talking about brain development.
As you know, there are many
ways this can get screwed up.
It can get screwed up by heredity,
as you'll hear about
from Matt State later.
It can get screwed up by disease
or environmental deprivation.
A convenient way of
conceptualizing this is that,
imagine that we have a
number of different measures
of brain maturation in
different parts of the brain,
and so on different processes,
but all these processes improve with age,
and in the case of a
developmental brain disorder,
it's a derailment, and you
see an accumulated deficit
as the person matures.
The question that we're really
interested in now is whether,
at the time of diagnosis, which often is
in early childhood in
many of these diseases
or even later, can we initiate a treatment
that can reverse the
consequence of the disease.
We can imagine, conceptually,
three potential outcomes.
The most dismal outcome is the
one illustrated on the top,
and that is that I can only intervene
during an early critical period,
and then if you miss that period,
maybe the damage has already
been done in utero prior
to birth, it's just too late
to initiate a treatment.
That's the most pessimistic point of view.
The most optimistic point
of view is that, indeed,
we can apply our great knowledge
of neurobiology to come up
with good treatments that may
actually reverse the course
of the disease and actually
restore normal function.
Probably, a realistic possibility
is the one in the middle,
the hopeful scenario, that
we can initiate treatments
that may prevent further decline.
The work in my lab is
addressing these questions
in different ways.
One of the ways we look at is
the genetically defined
disease called fragile X.
We've done a lot of work on that,
but we're also interested
in the consequences
of environmental deprivation,
particularly a disease called amblyopia,
and I'm gonna you about that work today.
Amblyopia is a not-uncommon
visual disability.
It affects approximately
3% of the world population,
and it's more prevalent in nations
where there's poor early-childhood
pediatric screening,
is this a consequence
of poor-quality vision
during infancy and early childhood,
and that poor quality could arise
because the eyes aren't
properly aligned at birth,
so the child is seeing double.
It can arise 'cause there's
a dense cataract in one eye
or a droopy eyelid, or it could arise
because there are different
refractive indices
in the two eyes, so you
can't focus an image
on both eyes at the same time.
The consequence is the same,
and it is usually a fairly
severe visual impairment
in one of the eyes.
If that optical abnormality
or what have you is corrected
very early in life, there's a good chance
to see some recovery of function,
but if that correction occurs later,
there's a very dismal prognosis.
Luckily, there are animal
models for this amblyopia.
In fact, every mammal
with binocular vision
will show a susceptibility to
poor-quality visual experience
during early life.
I'm gonna show you a cat
video; it's always popular;
(audience laughs)
to illustrate the visual
disability in a kitten.
What we're looking at is, that's
the top of a kitten's head,
and this kitten had been
deprived of normal vision
through one eye for only seven days
at about the fourth post-natal week,
and then that eye was unpatched,
and then now we're gonna
measure the consequences.
First, we're gonna measure
the vision in the good eye.
The way we do this, and when I
say we, it'd be very liberal.
This is actually worked
on by Donald Mitchell,
a collaborator of mine
at Dalhousie University,
and Don's been studying
this for many, many years.
He puts the animal in
a box on a jack stand,
and the animal learns to
jump down onto a placard
with the vertical stripes,
so the animal is reporting
whether it can resolve the stripes
by choosing the correct
placard to jump on,
and he gets a pat on the
back and a little bit
of kitten food, and they're
very happy to perform this task.
First we're gonna look at a
kitten performing the task
through the good eye that
had not been deprived.
You can see they're quite keen to do this.
They jump down, they
find the right stripes,
get a little liverwurst.
They can make the
stripes closer and closer
to get a measurement of visual acuity.
This is a way that they can determine
how well the animal can
resolve visual stimuli,
the same way you would at the eye doctor.
Now this is the same animal,
but now we're gonna do
this test through the eye
that had been only temporarily
deprived of vision,
only for seven days, and
what you're gonna see is,
this is a very severe visual impairment.
The good eye is being occluded
with a black contact lens,
so that the kitten is forced
to look through its lazy eye,
and you can see that it's
having great difficulty
in even seeing the stripes
versus the empty chamber there.
It's a significant visual
disability, and as I said,
this is a type of disability
that affects up to 3%
of the human population.
The visual disability will persist even
when the eye has been reopened
and the animal is allowed
to see through both eyes.
This is shown in this graph.
This is now a plot of the visual acuity,
the ability of the animal
to resolve those stripes
as a function of time after
the bad eye has been opened.
The green symbols show vision
through the non-deprived eye
and the blue symbols show the vision
through the deprived eye.
You can see that, although
there is a slight recovery,
there's not much, and there's actually
fairly severe visual disability compared
to the vision through the good eye.
This model of temporary
monocular deprivation
has been around for over
50 years, and many others,
probably maybe hundreds
of other scientists
have been studying this very intensively.
We've actually learned quite
a bit about the mechanisms
that serve this disruption
in the cortex, and yet,
our work has had very little impact
on how the clinical
management of amblyopia.
The question that I want
to address today is,
can the understanding
of the synaptic basis
for amblyopia suggest novel
treatments to promote recovery
that are better than
current standard of care?
The simple answer to
that question is, yes.
Here it is.
These are kittens that were
visually impaired in one eye,
a stable visual disability,
and a treatment was
initiated based on principles
of synaptic plasticity at this age;
this is now two months
after the deprived eye had been opened,
so about three months of age.
You can see that there is a
very rapid recovery of vision
through the deprived eye,
so essentially curing this
form of visual disability.
Hopefully I've gotten your attention
with this amazing result,
and now I'm gonna unpack it
for you and tell you what
that magical treatment was,
but to do so, I need to walk
you through a little bit
of background, which is the
visual system of mammals
with two eyes, often
kittens or mice or monkeys.
The visual pathway originates
with these retinal ganglion
cells in the two eyes.
They project centrally.
They relay in the lateral
genicular nucleus or LGN.
Then they go on and synapse on neurons
in primary visual cortex.
When visual experience is
normal through the two eyes,
those connections mature and
we have binocular vision.
When there's an imbalance
in vision to the two eyes,
it sets in motion a
stereotype choreography
of synaptic changes where the
inputs carrying information
from the deprived eye are weakened,
and the inputs carrying information
by the open eye eventually show
a compensatory strengthening.
We can measure these consequences
of that anatomical plasticity
functionally as well.
We can put a microelectrode
in primary visual cortex,
and we can record the
activity that's evoked
by stimulation of the
right eye or the left eye.
I'll just direct your attention
to these histograms on the top.
This is now the number of
nerve impulses triggered
in response to stimulation
of the right eye
and the left eye, prior
to any deprivation.
You can see this is a
neuron that responds happily
to stimulation of both eyes.
Fact, there's a slight ocular dominance,
slight preference for
stimulation of the right eye.
Now this right eyelid is closed,
and then the neuron is
recorded again later,
and what you can see is,
it's essentially lost all responsiveness
to stimulation of the eye
that had been deprived.
No wonder the kittens can't see.
We've disconnected the
cortex from that eye.
I mentioned that it is possible
to correct these visual disabilities
if you intervene early enough.
The current standard of care is
a therapy called patching therapy.
Essentially, that
comprises putting a patch,
usually an opaque patch,
over the strong eye
to force the weak eye to function,
and that can be successful.
When you patch the strong eye,
you'll get a recovery of
vision through the weak eye.
There are a number of
limitations to this approach,
not least of which is compliance,
because children don't like
to have these eye patches,
but also, the gains in the
amblyopic eye often come
at the expense of the good eye,
'cause you're now patching it.
There's little improvement
in binocular vision,
so no stereopsis, and again,
it's only effective if you
initiate this treatment
prior to age eight or so.
Let's get under the hood
and see what happens
during reverse patching.
Again, we're recording
now from a single neuron
in primary visual cortex.
We're gonna start with a
situation after a period
of monocular deprivation,
so we have a neuron here
that's responding only to the left eye.
There's no response to the right eye.
That's because we've already performed
a monocular deprivation,
so the kitten is amblyopic.
Now what we're gonna do is
we're gonna patch the strong eye
and we're gonna open the weak
eye and see what happens.
What happens is that
initially, you get a loss
of responsiveness to
the newly deprived eye,
but with time, you start to
get a gain of responsiveness
in the formerly deprived, now seeing eye.
This is good.
We can get a recovery, but it's not ideal.
It's not ideal because it
actually is a zero-sum game.
The gains that we're getting in this weak,
lazy eye are coming at the
expense of the strong eye.
As in the case of patching
therapy in humans,
this reverse patching in animal models
also shows a sensitive period.
This is a classic study done
by Blakemore and van Sluyters in cats,
showing that the ability to reverse
this ocular-dominance shift,
or this change in physiology
in the cortex, diminishes
greatly with age,
that by eight weeks of
age, it's very difficult
to get a reversal, and
it's essentially gone
by 12 to 14 weeks of age.
This same sort of pattern
is seen in any species
that's been looked at.
So, there are problems
with patching therapy,
but, these limitations notwithstanding,
they do demonstrate that we
can rejuvenate weak synapses,
we can rejuvenate these inputs
that previously were incapable
of invoking a response.
What we'd like to do is
understand that process
a little bit better, so
that maybe we could devise
a better way to restore function.
To understand where we're gonna go,
I have to introduce some of the some
of the simple principles
of synaptic plasticity.
The excitatory synapses in
our brains use glutamate
as a neurotransmitter.
Glutamate activates two types
of post-synaptic glutamate receptor,
glutamate-gated ion channels.
The AMPA receptor mediates
fast synaptic transmission,
and the NMDA receptor
is an important trigger
for modification of synaptic strength.
What we've learned over 30 or 40 years
of intensive effort is
that we can indeed modify
the strength of synaptic transmission,
and we do so by activating NMDA receptors.
Strong activation of
NMDA receptors will make
a synapse stronger,
and that's a phenomenon
we call long-term potentiation or LTP.
Modest activation of NMDA receptors leads
to the reverse form of plasticity called
long-term depression or LTD.
The NMDA receptor has an unusual property
that's actually very sensitive
to how well correlated pre-
and post-synaptic neurons are,
so strongly correlated
activity strongly activates
NMDA receptors, and you're more likely
to get a synaptic strengthening.
This is one fundamental feature
of what we call bidirectional
synaptic plasticity.
Another fundamental feature is
that that learning rule
actually is also modifiable.
If neurons are quieted
for a long period of time,
there's a shift in this function.
For example, the function
will shift to the left
if we put animals in
the dark, for instance.
This function will shift to
the left in visual cortex,
which has the net effect
of making the potentiation
more readily observed
and making depression more difficult.
We call that property metaplasticity.
It's a type of homeostatic plasticity
to make sure the network of synapses keeps
within a dynamic range.
Now, how are we gonna explain this effect
of reverse patching?
Let's go through this again.
We have a situation where we have a neuron
that responds only to
stimulation of one eye.
This eye has been
functionally disconnected.
Now we're going to close that strong eye,
and the first thing that happens is
that the neuron loses responsiveness
to the newly deprived eye.
This is believed to be a consequence
of these mechanisms of
long-term depression.
In fact, there's very, very good evidence
to support that statement.
This initial loss of responsiveness
is due to a diminution
of the strength of excitatory
synaptic transmission
from inputs carrying
information for that eye,
but something else has happened as well.
The other thing that's happened is,
imagine we have a situation
where the seeing eye is not strong enough
to evoke a response, and the
strong eye is not seeing.
As a consequence, the
activity in the cortex falls,
and this is the condition required
to induce this metaplasticity.
Eventually what we see is
the change in the rules
of the game, so this function
will slide to the left,
and this will allow the recovery
of the formerly-deprived, now seeing eye.
It can recover 'cause it's got
reasonably correlated activity.
It was very weak, and now
this weak activity is enough
to start to gain a toehold
and drive those synapses up.
I mentioned that there are
issues with patch therapy.
It's not ideal, and the question is,
can we use these principles
of metaplasticity
to restore function without
resorting to patching?
There is good reason to
believe that that's the case.
First, there have been a couple
of studies done by others,
where they've put animals
into complete darkness
after a period of monocular deprivation,
literally one or two weeks
of complete darkness.
Then the animals are
brought back into the light
with both eyes open, and
what they've observed is,
they can get a recovery of vision.
It can be quite dramatic,
but it does require weeks of darkness,
and that darkness cannot be interrupted,
even temporarily, by light exposure.
We wondered if we could
do better, again, based on
what we knew about this
metaplasticity property.
The experiment that we did
was to use an anesthetic
and inject both eyes with this anesthetic.
It's an anesthetic called tetrodotoxin,
but really, any drug that would block
sodium-dependent action
potentials would work.
Essentially what we're
doing is, in essence,
we're rebooting the visual system.
We are turning it off,
and then we're gonna let
it turn back on again.
The rationale here is that
we put this tetrodotoxin
into the eyes and we block
all impulse activity.
This curve slides to the left,
and this will promote
recovery of the weak input.
So what happens?
I wouldn't be telling you
this if it didn't work.
(audience laughs)
It works amazingly, amazingly.
This is work from mice here,
so I have to introduce a little bit.
Essentially, the only
thing that matters is
that the blue bars represent
the strength of one eye,
the eye on the opposite side of the head,
the contralateral eye, and
the yellow bar represents
the strength of the other
eye, the ipsilateral eye.
If you don't do anything
to a mouse, the heights
of these bars wax and wane,
but they don't change too much.
If you monocularly deprive
a mouse, as we've done here,
it goes from here, where
we've closed the blue eye,
so this response is depressed,
and it stays depressed.
It never recovers spontaneously,
but if we follow that
monocular deprivation
with this bilateral
injection of tetrodotoxin
to turn the eyes off,
when the TTX wears off,
we see a rapid recovery of
vision to the deprived eye.
This is the magic treatment
that we did in the kittens.
In these animals, tetrodotoxin
was injected bilaterally.
In this case, we did two
injections into both eyes,
'cause we didn't want to take any chances,
but you can see, which is
a really remarkable recovery of sight.
This is an example of one experiment
where initially we failed.
We failed because the
injections weren't successful
and they didn't block the
pupillary light reflex,
so we knew we hadn't
blocked impulse activity.
We were disappointed.
Animal kept maturing.
We wondered what we were gonna do with it.
We said, oh, let's try it again.
So we tried it again, by
now at the ripe old age
of five months, with a
single injection of TTX,
and again we saw this great recovery.
We're excited about that,
because it's a brief
manipulation, even very late.
Just to compare, this is five
months of age or 20 weeks.
You can see, that's way
beyond what's possible
with reverse occlusion.
Just to wrap up, we're
seeing recovery at older ages
than is possible for reverse occlusion.
Recovery is very rapid;
it occurs over the course of a week;
it's 100% complete,
and the recovery of the
weak eye does not come
at the expense of the strong eye.
Of course, what we wanna
know now is precisely,
how did this retinal activation work,
and can we actually
translate this knowledge
into better therapies for human amblyopia?
And with that, I'll just thank the people
who did all the work,
and our funding sources.
(audience applauds)
(electronic music)